Ashritha: Yeah.
Ashritha: So can I directly use your mic?
Ashritha: Or use mine.
Ashritha: Yeah, you can use my mind.
Ashritha: You can't hear it.
Ashritha: Me commute?
Ashritha: J? Or… Yeah.
Ashritha: Okay, okay.
Ashritha: So today, I… I'd like to introduce you the…
Ashritha: Power layer, the layer 3 was, our machine.
Ashritha: lending systems.
Ashritha: And this layer is the most important and complex.
Ashritha: A layer, or the whole system.
Ashritha: And, this is the core, machine learning function layer.
Ashritha: And I divided this layer into 3.
Ashritha: important part.
Ashritha: Each… each path has its unique, functions.
Ashritha: And I will… First to introduce the… What layers?
Ashritha: Structure to you.
Ashritha: First, and then I will introduce you some.
Ashritha: night.
Ashritha: their customer input, and I'll show you how to… House assistant, We deal with this impulse.
Ashritha: So… First, Leah's Ray.
Ashritha: We permanently use these two fails to train our model.
Ashritha: This one… The first one has
Ashritha: nearly 200,000 rows, and the row is to… is, like, like a product rotor, and this one has…
Ashritha: even more roles, because this one dispels cartoon's attribability annual pals.
Ashritha: So… It could be 10 times what was the first bills.
Ashritha: And of course, Plus a fail.
Ashritha: We… primarily use this.
Ashritha: Three column information.
Ashritha: The first one is, product type ID.
Ashritha: The… the second one… the second one, the third one is the short or the extended description.
Ashritha: Which could be used to… formed a… The high-level dimensional data cloud.
Ashritha: And this one is used in the… the M3P.
Ashritha: Consensus and statistics.
Ashritha: pumps.
Ashritha: And we will use product ID and attribute name and value to train the second layers.
Ashritha: attributes.
Ashritha: Yeah, this is a WOTC, D… this response.
Ashritha: I will skip this.
Ashritha: So now I will, introduce you the technical overview on each part.
Ashritha: Layer 3, the primary… Raw it is received.
Ashritha: Input from layer 1 layer 2 cannot fully resolve the customer's request.
Ashritha: So, the first part, Or… or this layer… this… this top layer is to train The… the model.
Ashritha: And get, adapt.
Ashritha: So…
Ashritha: We use this.
Ashritha: Major trainer model.
Ashritha: to produce I would.
Ashritha: data… datasets, layer. They said… Image.
Ashritha: And, after training, we get, the metrics result, or… or the… information.
Ashritha: And we get two artifacts.
Ashritha: So, this is how… So, sub-layer works.
Ashritha: So, after we get a customer request, It's like a long pace.
Ashritha: The encoder produced a 384-dimensional query vector.
Ashritha: And we… Use our trained Artifact to do a compare… comparison.
Ashritha: And find the, most likely 50… 50 product type candidates.
Ashritha: And, get, primarily scores.
Ashritha: And handed it to the second sublayer.
Ashritha: And, this is its performance.
Ashritha: it… It could only consume 0.2 to 1.4 milliseconds.
Ashritha: Well, you… the traditional method could… could… consume… 30 minutes, many minutes, milliseconds.
Ashritha: And now we went to the, second sublayer.
Ashritha: So…
Ashritha: Yeah, so from the first sub-year, we get the top 5… top 50 candidly, likely neighborhoods from the first sub-year.
Ashritha: And, and this layer… So, so this layer, we first train,
Ashritha: Train the model and, get, are defense.
Ashritha: Those artifacts is, trample, curtains, this, just…
Ashritha: This way, so they can't, or… information.
Ashritha: Yes, and… We… the first sublayer, we get the… Likely, product type.
Ashritha: And for this layer, we choose, most likely prototype, and, School always… is…
Ashritha: attribute value pairs and get, suburbs, grades.
Ashritha: Yeah, this is the latest performance.
Ashritha: So, product-type voting only… Consume, less than 0.1 milliseconds.
Ashritha: And for the last sub-layer, we… Do a parent attribute screening.
Ashritha: You'll cease.
Ashritha: Eglutin.
Ashritha: And in this layer, we will also consign… take… take the…
Ashritha: The usage put… the usage… Like, frequency… the usage, or the frequency, or the…
Ashritha: A product to take into account.
Ashritha: And we get the final… compete in the school.
Ashritha: And in this sublayer, we'll consume 2 to 10 milliseconds.
Ashritha: So the total layer 3, the link latency, Could be 21 milliseconds.
Ashritha: So, it's less than our estimated 50 milliseconds.
Ashritha: And, we yield… 180… 100 and, 20, test to…
Ashritha: Test all the layers function well.
Ashritha: And I will show you some, most likely, customer request inputs.
Ashritha: And how these layers could deal with those inputs.
Ashritha: We primarily have 4 scenarios.
Ashritha: And, this is the background.
Ashritha: You can see, we have… Dividend pens or imports.
Ashritha: And, after layer 1's extractions inputs.
Ashritha: were redacted to neutral language, like texts that are accompanied by optional structure belt.
Ashritha: The Layer 2 is a real engine layer.
Ashritha: Which… It is low… it's like to do, row-based matching.
Ashritha: From this rate level.
Ashritha: a matching.
Ashritha: The Tier 1 is to do, example.
Ashritha: parts Langarduca.
Ashritha: If it… if it could be… Matched, matched.
Ashritha: We could directly get, confidence Wang.
Ashritha: And, pass it to the Layer 4.
Ashritha: If there's a first tier, could not match. We tried the…
Ashritha: Tell 2, the manufacturer, the expressive matching, and if it could be matched, we get,
Ashritha: Start competence score, 0.85.
Ashritha: And then translate, so… contest into the S3 to do, domestic match.
Ashritha: And if the tier 2 could not match, we tried to compare…
Ashritha: To match the numeric value and the unit look up against the
Ashritha: to a table, and we get a relatively low confidence score, and pass it to the state.
Ashritha: So, this rate process all requests that Layer 2 cannot fully resolve.
Ashritha: And, this is, Senator Guang.
Ashritha: The first scenario awarded by information density from the highest to lowest.
Ashritha: So, in the scenario one, way, the…
Ashritha: We have, most likely, most detailed natural language description was identified for that type.
Ashritha: The likely input could be, looking for,
Ashritha: 24, with damped motorway with spring returned, and need to control, 0 to 10, way… stigma.
Ashritha: Next seconds, which entirely will work.
Ashritha: So we could know That first low part number is provided.
Ashritha: That's… we have the description.
Ashritha: Like, that's a, attribute.
Ashritha: When you pairs, this is sufficient detail.
Ashritha: So, how's the layer to… deal with it, and this is the possible outcomes for layer 2.
Ashritha: So…
Ashritha: We don't have pair number, part number, the product number, and we don't have the manufacturer information. We only have the numeric and unit.
Ashritha: We could extract this information.
Ashritha: And so, their true producer is no usable support.
Ashritha: And, then… So this case will pass to layer screen to process.
Ashritha: So, first, we will… So there's very well, encoder. So…
Ashritha: initial language information into a high-level 384-dimensional vector into the
Ashritha: to the system. And we already trained,
Ashritha: This is, Facebook AI search.
Ashritha: image.
Ashritha: To do a match.
Ashritha: in, High-level… high-dimensional space.
Ashritha: to… To, compare in the data cloud.
Ashritha: We actually compared the…
Ashritha: Distance with the… with each cluster, and, the angle, or the geometry direction with the…
Ashritha: The data cloud to get the first top likely product at a time.
Ashritha: And the M3… the layer… the sublayer 2, the second sublayer dual voting, And the way that…
Ashritha: The, most likely product type, like, like, it could be the damper act… actual… actuator.
Ashritha: or the, or what other product type.
Ashritha: Because… This could… could be the… it…
Ashritha: it matches 43 per dots, so… We get,
Ashritha: A permanent score, a competence product type competence score, like, 35.62.
Ashritha: And, so… and this score could… is… is higher… it's safe.
Ashritha: than 0.80. So this could be considered as high constant suspension.
Ashritha: And then, the last several year scores.
Ashritha: Across four, attributes under this product type.
Ashritha: This information is extracted from the… Context.
Ashritha: Like this.
Ashritha: And for the attribute score.
Ashritha: So, first 3 is higher than 80…
Ashritha: 0.85, so it's waterprocessed, and the last one, is less than… 8 port…
Ashritha: 0.85, so it could hand out to human… Review.
Ashritha: And, this is the second scenario.
Ashritha: We have complete information.
Ashritha: But no standard terminology.
Ashritha: And, this is… And this scenario could, Show how our… Symmetric…
Ashritha: Mechanisms to deal with this condition.
Ashritha: And this is what the machine learning… Good, good tool, to deal.
Ashritha: Like, the customer input is, like, wait, he needs, needs, some mister that…
Ashritha: clumps onto a pipe, then the 10,000 can for an outdoor air handle.
Ashritha: So… It could be translated to, the customer provides
Ashritha: This song, the information is, like, We know the product type.
Ashritha: The resistance value, the mounting type, and the intensity element.
Ashritha: But, the input is not… is not… standard technology.
Ashritha: But we… after we're mapping those information into the… high-level… Dimension of space.
Ashritha: We could… could… It could be, gotcha.
Ashritha: Who?
Harsha Tummala: I had a small question. So you mentioned customer input, right?
Harsha Tummala: And aren't we trying to, create something which is, like,
Harsha Tummala: Like a catalog, creator.
Harsha Tummala: It looks like the customer is doing the catalog search instead.
Ashritha: Yes, it's like to… Where we collect the customers.
Ashritha: This is the primary information from the customer's input.
Ashritha: And to do, matching.
Ashritha: Yeah, you can go.
Ashritha: To do a matching in our trained artifacts, like, the chin… Clusters in our… Through the cloud.
Ashritha: Amazing.
Harsha Tummala: I mean, just…
Harsha Tummala: I think I was just lost on, why, we were… we were, doing queries, or, like.
Harsha Tummala: What sort of parts the customers were looking for.
Harsha Tummala: And that's it.
Harsha Tummala: Because technically, what we're trying to do is take in the…
Harsha Tummala: Catalog data given by customers, and trying to
Harsha Tummala: Refine it into usable catalog data.
Ashritha: You…
Ashritha: So… it's like… In my mind, I think we are trying to do some… Product matching job.
Ashritha: To help the customers to identify
Ashritha: Which product is the most possible Wang.
Harsha Tummala: That sounds a little different, right, isn't it?
Harsha Tummala: I don't know, I think Ashita, it helped, just like… Am I… am I saying something that's not in line, Ashita?
Harsha Tummala: Oil.
Ashritha: Like, what… you understood the question, right?
Ashritha: Yeah. Okay, Aharsha, do you mind repeating the question again?
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, the question is,
Harsha Tummala: I see you discussing cases where the customer's trying to find a certain type of product.
Harsha Tummala: But technically, what we're trying to do is…
Harsha Tummala: take the data from, like, CSV, PDF, etc, etc, whatever it is.
Harsha Tummala: And turn it into usable catalog data.
Harsha Tummala: But, like, looking at this, the use case seems to be,
Harsha Tummala: How do I help the customer find the most accurate product?
Harsha Tummala: In our database, which is already there, yeah.
David Mine: Yeah, this seems to me to be something where it takes the,
David Mine: The customer is searching for something.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah.
David Mine: Well, I think what we were looking for is that the customer is providing
David Mine: A catalog, and they just got it from…
David Mine: you know, 7 or 8 different suppliers. It's all different formats, and there are varying levels of effort put into
David Mine: how robust those catalogs are. So in order to be helpful to them ordering from all these catalogs.
David Mine: What we would want to do is standardize
David Mine: The names for things, standardize, the product types, the attributes, so that way it all kind of feels the same to the catalog.
David Mine: Or it feels the same to the customer.
David Mine: And then they could… we could, you know, search on that. There are other ways to improve the customer catalog experience as well in searching, but right now, it's that ingestion piece, right? If I have
David Mine: 20 CSV files from 20 different suppliers, how can it appear to be the same catalog?
David Mine: Where everything's in the right place, with the same name.
Ashritha: Oh, yes.
Harsha Tummala: how we get the data into PIMS, in a way.
Harsha Tummala: Rather than, how.
Harsha Tummala: search for the dynamics panel.
Ashritha: Ha, so I think the… I mean, if I understand it correctly… Yeah, yeah, so I… Just to,
Ashritha: To prove the system is.
Ashritha: Blue Bust, and so I just chose the most.
Ashritha: Like, vague input, further input to test the… how our… Like, the second layers.
Ashritha: No, I think, Harsha, like, is the confusion about usable output, like, I think by usable output, we are trying to say that, he is… he would, in the ML layer itself, he's gonna, like, normalize the data and validate it against the,
Ashritha: industry stand… the conventions that you were… nomenclature that you were talking about, right? So that…
Ashritha: whatever just David just mentioned, we are ingesting it into PIMS, not to make it…
Ashritha: how do I say, search efficient for the customer, but make it
Ashritha: Aligned with the industry, prescribed nomenclature.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, exactly. I mean, I think I got thrown off by the example that Leo just gave.
Harsha Tummala: Okay, okay. Which was… which was just, like, a customer specifying a certain type of product. Like, if you go back to, like, Layer 2, the example that was there in Layer 2,
Harsha Tummala: Like, the examples I gave, just up a little more. If you can scroll up a little.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, like, the input… oh, sorry, can you go to the layer 2 input? Go down, go down, sorry.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, this one. So, need a thermistor that clamps onto a pipe, the 10K kind?
Harsha Tummala: This looked like a search criteria for the customer, and that's what threw me off. I think, I think what Leo wanted to convey was.
Harsha Tummala: How these, how these… How the words… how the words are, like, connected to each.
Ashritha: Yeah.
Harsha Tummala: In terms of similarity and how they're ranked according to similarities.
Ashritha: But, usually imports could be standardized and not so vague.
Ashritha: And,
Harsha Tummala: Yay.
Ashritha: And I think we can perfectly deal with that situation. So, I mean, in the most badly…
Ashritha: situation, I hope… we could deal with those cases, that's what I want to show you.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, this makes sense. I was thrown off completely by the way the question was phrased, and that's it.
Ashritha: Yes.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, because even the previous question seemed to be phrased in a similar manner, where a person was looking for something, rather than giving information.
Ashritha: Yes, yes.
Harsha Tummala: So there's no…
Ashritha: I…
Harsha Tummala: It was just a communication thing, and that's it. Bye-bye.
Ashritha: Yes.
Ashritha: Yeah, I know. So… I just want to show you the, most bad knee condition the… how the…
Ashritha: mechanisms.
Harsha Tummala: Input can be, yeah.
Ashritha: delicate.
Ashritha: Yeah, yes, yes.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, I got it, I got what you meant now, yeah.
Ashritha: Yes.
Ashritha: It's, like, in this scenario,
Ashritha: So we could… we could let the customer terminology diverges from, Can you… Canonical database vocabulary.
Ashritha: So it could be… could understand all the synonymi relationships.
Ashritha: And it gets, Write complaint scores.
Ashritha: And the instantaneous way.
Ashritha: If the input contains ambiguous product type.
Ashritha: Like, the customer's input could be, like.
Ashritha: Need pricing on this manufacturer, like, this product.
Ashritha: And with some attribute value pairs.
Ashritha: So, because this product… that type could be vague, it could turn… could match in several,
Ashritha: Different product types.
Ashritha: Like, these two different kinds of products.
Ashritha: And with, similar… Competence scores, or working competency scores.
Ashritha: So, lastly must identify such ambiguity explicit, rather than commit it… commit to a single prototype.
Ashritha: This is what they choose output.
Ashritha: The layer one, the part number, could not exactly match.
Ashritha: And, for the manufacturer, way.
Ashritha: We could, we could, definitely, accurately match this.
Ashritha: manufactured.
Ashritha: We… so we could get a… First, the competence score, 0.85.
Ashritha: And, yes, we… we ejects, ejects and value pairs.
Ashritha: So, for this condition, it… It also needs this data to process.
Ashritha: So we… first, we embed the… Useful information.
Ashritha: into a vector.
Ashritha: So, the top 5, candidates products.
Ashritha: Could be, these two.
Ashritha: And, their prototype confidence scores could… Could be, similar, but… Notably very large.
Ashritha: So, because the product type confidence score is less than 0.60, So, the ambiguity tape check.
Ashritha: This means… No matter how… how high the… Suburb… attribution… Attributes, value, pair, scores.
Ashritha: is… it could… it's… what's a product?
Ashritha: type with its attribute pair scores need to be sent to human.
Ashritha: To do a human review.
Ashritha: Yes, and we'll… and the system will inform It's a… it's a human.
Ashritha: The product type is ambiguous.
Ashritha: And, the… and provide the human some basic information, and the most likely candidates.
Ashritha: And in this scenario, It's, so, frequency, or the product use.
Ashritha: Could take into a higher level, or can say… can say it.
Ashritha: High level or weights, because
Ashritha: The voting, score is very…
Ashritha: It's almost the same between the… The two product types.
Ashritha: So… The consensus results could… More likely to use, product frequency.
Ashritha: And usage information to choose which one could be the most suitable.
Ashritha: And, the last… for the last scenario, We could all…
Ashritha: So, for the input, we could only have some first information.
Ashritha: like… We could only extract the information, the useful information, like HAAC, pipe, temporary digital monitoring, like this.
Ashritha: so, this request does not distinguish between sensor and some more state, and most specific manuals are given.
Ashritha: So, for the Layer 2,
Ashritha: It has no actionable extraction, no numeric manual, no manufacturer mention.
Ashritha: For the latest wave.
Ashritha: So the last day processing will permanently use the usage count prior.
Ashritha: become… due to… Do a judgment between different products.
Ashritha: Like, we… in the first… in the second layer, or the… This way.
Ashritha: We get, most unlikely for that type.
Ashritha: It's a temperature sensor.
Ashritha: And we get a product type competence score.
Ashritha: And the attributes under, this product type are scored, because the customer provides no specific, specific values.
Ashritha: This is our algorithm to… To get the scores.
Ashritha: Yes, so the distance is comparable across candidates' value, and the usage count prior… prior dominates the ranking.
Ashritha: You can say, what the candidates get the… Similar… working squad.
Ashritha: So we used the second, Judgment Like, the usage prior to…
Ashritha: Identify which one could be the best.
Ashritha: So, this one could be… could be the best common yields.
Ashritha: Because the frequency of this one could be higher than other ones.
Ashritha: Yes.
Ashritha: And for its… attributes.
Ashritha: Like, the mounting candidates.
Ashritha: this one could be the best.
Ashritha: And, for the… Resistance, all candidates, this one would be the best.
Ashritha: Because the information is dispersed, so all the confidence final values fall in the range 0.2 to 0.45.
Ashritha: So… Because the, the score is so low.
Ashritha: This could be less than 0.50, so it will be flagged as flag unclear.
Ashritha: And we will keep this juice.
Ashritha: Information into our… Looking into our datasets.
Ashritha: Yes, and it's… This is… this is how we deal with
Ashritha: Those vague and thirsty information.
Ashritha: In the last way.
Ashritha: So, so, this, these four scenarios is the most…
Ashritha: Likely, you know, better conditions, less they could meet.
Ashritha: in graduates.
Ashritha: Yeah, this is a table for the four scenarios.
Ashritha: And I also made a, curating coverage matrix.
Ashritha: Spore… tend to, to make testing Like, in the most significant a checkpoint.
Ashritha: Yes.
Ashritha: I think that's all.
Ashritha: Cheer.
Harsha Tummala: I had, two questions, mainly. One was,
Harsha Tummala: where do these layers… I mean, it's… it's a question for later, but, where do you think these layers will kind of reside, from, like, a…
Harsha Tummala: to make, hosting slash infrastructure point of view, as in…
Harsha Tummala: all this… most of this, like, all of this is really impressive and really nice, but, I… I'm not sure how we can host this, and how we can,
Harsha Tummala: Build this pipeline out, but…
Harsha Tummala: Not on a local machine, but something which is more up to scale.
Ashritha: So, this positive deployment. Yeah.
Ashritha: I think it could… directly, mounting…
Ashritha: laptop. We cannot do it because it cannot scale, right?
Ashritha: So, Hershey, I think for now, we can probably do it locally, but, if…
Ashritha: If we, like, decide on the one… any particular models or lightweight LLMs, we can see if those are available on Azure and are deployed over there? Does that answer the question?
Harsha Tummala: But it's… it's just a train of thought that you guys… I just want you guys to be thinking, and that's it.
Ashritha: Okay.
Harsha Tummala: It's nothing that's, pressing, yeah.
Harsha Tummala: Because this all seems really good, but I forget that this looks more like an experimental project than, like, something which is, you know, more usable than yet.
Ashritha: yes, so… If you want to maybe change the model, or… You want to…
Ashritha: Mount it to, like, other plantable, or… that you… to… to… You'll use more… you'll use…
Ashritha: Much amount of the… the data fresh… update data to train the model, I think it's…
Ashritha: It's relatively easy to do it.
Ashritha: Are you searching for something?
Ashritha: Yeah, that's about it. You had one more question?
Harsha Tummala: This is different, I just wanted to check in and see, if you guys are able to use linear and,
Harsha Tummala: If… if the free tier was enough for you guys.
Ashritha: Okay, so the… yeah, we… I signed up for Linear, and I got all the access, I mean, with all the… the… I… I mean, I just… I thought that…
Ashritha: this is good enough for us to create the custom fields and stuff like that, but, since we… I mean, I don't know if you remember, we were like, we'll do a 3-day, sprint, right? So, probably, like, our one cycle is 3 days.
Ashritha: So, but then linear has, the minimum, cycle is one week, so, I don't know how to go about that over there.
Harsha Tummala: It should… technically, you don't have to set a cycle in linear, right? You could…
Harsha Tummala: Have a sprint board for almost, like, every single
Harsha Tummala: Every single 3-day cycle that you're planning to do.
Ashritha: Okay, but our… sorry, you were saying something?
Harsha Tummala: No, sir, Tom. I mean, or,
Harsha Tummala: the way you kind of, I think… I think the way you, create tasks would be for, like, a 3-day cycle, and…
Harsha Tummala: I mean, I'm just thinking out loud. So, like, if you have a backlog, and if you have, like, the in-cycle tasks, then I think you can just move things around.
Harsha Tummala: For your 3-day period, and then, do it for the rest.
Harsha Tummala: Like, in a similar fashion.
Ashritha: Okay, but,
Ashritha: I thought, like, I… I mean, I kind of web-coded a custom board, so I just used, Node.js, and React, and, kind of…
Ashritha: spawned up a small, server with, like, I… it's not fancy, just vibe-coded it, so it's also interactable, we… I… we could just, like, drag-drop, and, I can also, like, archive whatever progress that we have done, so the team gets the editor access, and I get… sorry, the team gets the view access, and I get the editor access, because, we do Scrum calls
Ashritha: Monday and Wednesday. So, for now, I mean, as of today in the afternoon, I kind of thought that probably this is the most easiest one.
Ashritha: linear…
Ashritha: Yeah, you're right, I thought about it. We could just create a backlog and, play around those definitions, or maybe, like, one cycle, in linear terms is basically 3 days in, in the agentic scrum that we defined. But…
Ashritha: again, there were, like, few other settings that I had to change, like workflow settings, and I had to, like, add a few more states.
Ashritha: unopened, which are not defined. I had to, like, create new labels and stuff like that. So that was too much of UI work, so I thought, webcoding is much easier than me learning how to go about linear now.
Harsha Tummala: Makes sense, I mean, if you guys can figure out just hosting and, like, doing everything about it, then more than… you guys should do whatever you can about it.
Ashritha: Yeah, yeah.
Harsha Tummala: And eating, that's it.
Ashritha: Yeah, yeah. So, I mean, it's quite… it's actually good, like, it does not restrict you with any templates or fields, so that's why I thought I would get started with it, but then, I mean, I didn't think about the cycle thingy and other, stuff, but then as I went ahead, I felt like it was, like.
Ashritha: not restricting, but maybe if I will… if I get to spend more time on it, probably I'll figure it out, but then we had to, like, keep pro… make, keep a progress, like, a visible progress of what we have done this week, so I had to bring up some UI for this, so I thought, let me just get done with this, and maybe over the weekend I can sit and play around.
Harsha Tummala: Makes sense. Also, I had a question, very random one.
Harsha Tummala: Why the 3-day cycle, though, compared to a week, for example?
Ashritha: Okay, so that's what the Agent Tech Scrum prescribes, so by definition, and
Ashritha: It's like the first… since, we don't have… we don't have to spend the entire week, like, the conventional week, or, like, two weeks of time in coding, it's more like…
Ashritha: deciding and breaking down the problem statement, and it's more of prompt engineering work later on. So, like, we thought that this would best suit the
Ashritha: current dynamics of the project, as in, the first day, we would just define the spec cards, in very detail, like, okay, what this task is about, what would the test cases be, who would write the test cases, is it the human, like, is it one among us, or probably the…
Ashritha: agent itself, and stuff like that. And, like, one day in between, we would just spend the entire day to, review the work it, it has done, it produced. And third day, we would just give a demo slash, review of what
Ashritha: we did over, Monday and Tuesday, suppose. So we thought, like, 3 days is a good amount of time, to get the entire cycle complete, wherein that happens in a 2-week time in a traditional scrum
Ashritha: scenario. So we're just, like, experimenting this, and by definition, this is what, the… the Scrum org, prescribes
Ashritha: A tick to be, like, a 3-rate, sprint.
Harsha Tummala: Okay. Yeah, just a question for my knowledge, that's all.
Ashritha: Yeah, yeah.
Harsha Tummala: Got it. Okay, so whatever you guys are comfortable with in the end. And also, like, the thing was, as Lou was presenting, I was… I was just getting so confused, because all of his examples were in, like, this,
Harsha Tummala: Like, like a user manner where, where someone is searching for something, or when someone is, like.
Harsha Tummala: looking for a product, and our whole use case was centered around, like, curating the product itself, so, like, it just constantly threw me out in this, state of confusion. And, that's… that was my, I think.
Harsha Tummala: That was my question in the middle of the meeting.
Ashritha: Yeah, I understood. Yeah, I think his example was more, like, to just make it explainable. Yeah, it's the most dangerous conditions Leia could…
Ashritha: Yeah. Yeah, it just… just shows this, because I think it's a…
Ashritha: like, in our, primarily testing, the accuracy is almost, like, 90… 95% on 200… 2,000 training samples, so I think the,
Ashritha: In the common… in the normal imports, so…
Ashritha: For the machine learning system to deal with, if this information is… it could not be,
Ashritha: looking be up.
Ashritha: be bad, I think. It could deal with it, those information smoothly.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, I mean, that was it. It was just, like, something on clarity that kind of, threw me off, and that's it. But other than that, that's it. I think one thing to think about is just, like, how… where these layers can live.
Harsha Tummala: When we're trying to build an application at scale.
Harsha Tummala: It can just be in theory, doesn't have to be worked out perfectly, but, like, I feel like designing something with that in mind.
Harsha Tummala: Helps actually achieve that goal.
Harsha Tummala: Whereas, when you design something in a purely experimental basis, where, you try to just create a layer which does everything in the best way possible on your local.
Harsha Tummala: might not exactly translate to, like, a at-scale application as we move further. It could… I mean, in the end, it could be something which is like a… like a virtual… like a… like, just a virtual machine-hosted, kind of system, too.
Harsha Tummala: Which is… which is fine, but it's also very inefficient in a way, so, like, that's why I'm trying to get you guys to think about it in… think about it from, like, a… from, like, a…
Harsha Tummala: MLOps slash AIOps kind of perspective.
Ashritha: Yeah, makes sense.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, that's it. That's pretty much all my questions from this.
Harsha Tummala: And… it would also help, like, if you could share this document with us, mainly so that I can just spend, like, an hour or 30 minutes just, like, slowly going through it and understanding, different parts of it.
Ashritha: So, because the time is limited, so I just skipped many technical details.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, exactly. I kind of got that, too. I mean, it's tough to… it's tough to present something in an hour which is this technically heavy, so…
Ashritha: It…
Harsha Tummala: I mean, I would tell you today, but .
Ashritha: Yes, if you want to say it, I will send you the four detailed documents.
Ashritha: You can see.
Harsha Tummala: 100%, that'd be really helpful.
Harsha Tummala: I'd want to go through that.
Harsha Tummala: Just for my reference, because, like, it's just very interesting to look at.
Ashritha: Yeah, I'll put this along the action items that I'll be sending in the evening today.
Harsha Tummala: Jakes up, yeah.
Ashritha: Yeah. We also wanted to go over the architecture part, but then I think we're just on time. Maybe next week, or maybe we can just send over those documents as well, you can just, like, take a look.
Ashritha: And if you have any… I mean, it's pretty simple and self-explanatory. If we have any questions, we can discuss it in our next meeting.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah, makes sense. I mean, also, just like, just in case you guys want to meet
Harsha Tummala: twice in a week, we could also, like, schedule that ad hoc, as in, if you have more to present, we could just decide on a… decide on another slot, and we could get that done as well. That's an option to you guys.
Ashritha: Oh, okay. I think we'll just think about this as a team, Ellie.
Harsha Tummala: Again, like, I'm just putting all options on the table for you guys, and that's it.
Ashritha: Yeah, yeah.
Harsha Tummala: Yeah. So, sending the document completely works. I'll go through it and send it.
Ashritha: Okay, yeah.
Ashritha: Okay.
Ashritha: Cool, and see you guys next week. Bye-bye.
David Mine: Yeah, thanks.
David Mine: Dude.
Harsha Tummala: Thank you so much.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But…